Indianapolis is on the line Jake's with
us hi Jake how are you hi Dave I'm doing
great how about you better than I
deserve what's up so I am 16 I'm going
on 17 and about two weeks now and I love
my mother
traditional the fact that he hasn't
really adapted to okay I'm having
trouble hearing you you're not speaking
directly into your phone do you hear me
better yes sir thank you your mother is
a traditional mother and what's your
question so I think around 50 to 70 to
80 km are fulfilling ecommerce women
you're making $50,000 a month at 16
years old yes yes I telling me the truth
yes sir I do
commerce so I run dropshipping website
through Shopify I do amazon to ebay
arbitrage and just a bunch of like
various side hustles and usually go
through the Internet and my question is
it has no right be I'm doing this
because and I have all my all my profits
stored in a PayPal account he says he is
going on my bank account and I would
love to tell her but like I said with
her being so traditional I already know
that she will be very very skeptical of
what I'm doing and she I'm fearing that
she's gonna put an end to it just
because she she's already told me
because I've expressed my passion
willing to be an entrepreneur and she's
traditional in the way how much is in
her PayPal account I got a little bit
over three hundred thousand so you've
been doing this for four or five months
six months no it's been about eight
months the first few months low and it
picked up it picked up rather fast
where's your father
he divorce
different states not in your life I mean
we talk I wouldn't say these you know
policies or oil comments are you in a
good friend a friend I guess are you in
a good church yes sir
how do you feel about your pastor very
very close have you talked to him about
this I have not no well I wouldn't tell
your friends I'd be very unwise or I'd
be very all eyes okay so how large is
the church that you go to about 30
people ok very small okay yes
[Music]
well here's kind of what's going on in
my head you if you have the ability to
make fifty thousand dollars a month you
you know as soon as you're 18 years old
you can go do whatever you want to do
right right and that's just about a year
away yeah yeah okay so if you were my
son and you were doing this and you told
me you don't want to go to college and
you want to move out and be an
entrepreneur I would say have at it dude
make it fifty thousand dollars a month
my god right I'm not saying I don't know
if you can do that for the rest of your
life you may have just caught a wave
right here and you know as you know
things on the internet change rapidly
yeah and you could I don't know what all
you're doing here
I've never heard of anybody doing the
volume you're doing doing the things you
described but uh oh well I run I run
three different websites and I felt
different looking nice I know what
you're doing I just never heard anybody
pull this off at the volume you're
pulling it off so I'm I'm not
questioning your integrity I'm believing
you but I'm just saying you're doing
something pretty unusual in it so I
don't know how sustainable it is
long-term and so I would tell you number
one I would pull out at 18 and go start
and keep doing this and just build your
own thing out and have a blast and go
make some money while you can I would
not say you're gonna do this 20 years
because you're not it's not gonna be
it's not gonna exist in 20 years
there's too much change on the way
business is done on the internet it you
know you might have a two year window
you might have a five year window I
don't know and so I would commit to
myself if I were you that when the thing
does turn down I might want to seek out
an education at that point to give me
knowledge to do other things and it'd be
great to have some business acumen from
a business degree if you're sitting on a
couple million dollars you know so
knowledge and knowledge is valuable
going to college is valuable do you have
to do that to make a living well crud
now dude I mean you're killing it you
know so I go pile up as much money as
you can so that that's part of our thing
I'm really uncomfortable participating
in you deceiving your mother my fear is
we have such a close relationship yeah
and I just I think deception is never a
good rule and I don't want to hide it I
just I didn't know that's not true you
you have hidden it from her so you
wanted to okay so you feel bad about it
but you've got your reasons for hiding
it are bigger than your reasons for
disclosure right now and so what I'm
thinking what I'm trying to get in my
head is I would love for you to search
out someone that is trusted by you
spiritually and with business acumen and
that is trusted by her that could
mediate this discussion with the two of
you okay I could participate with you
sitting down and going okay mom our
friend George is here he understands
business and the internet and he
understands spiritual things and values
and he cares about both you and me and I
wanted I wanted him to be present
because I want to tell you some things
have been going on
I have $400,000 $300,000 this is the
stuff I've been doing on the internet
I'm very good at it I'm a child prodigy
you know you are
but I I think you just sitting down with
your mom is not gonna go well okay and
so I'm trying to pull in that right
person
that could kind of be a mentor to you
and give you a little buffer but it's
got to be someone she trusts because if
you bring in some character that she
thinks is a character she's gonna think
they influenced you and so yeah I'm not
I want you to develop some kind of a
strategy or a plan like that that allows
you to not deceive your mom anymore okay
in the net and I take you in one yeah it
may take you a month to put it together
and that's okay and I'm okay with you
leaving your money your PayPal account
you do whatever you want to do that's
all fine there's no danger with any of
that and I'm okay with you continuing to
do all of this and I'm okay with you
coming straight out of high school and
making 600 grand a year
dadgum life's rough you know but again I
don't think that's sustainable because
the current methodologies that you're
using will not be there five years from
today and an education will give you the
ability to do things that are
sustainable and maybe step into the next
thing with a little more zest
I also don't want you to have this an
unusual success at a young age and it's
the only time you have success because
you don't do foundational things that
lead you into success when you're 32 as
well as 22 so Wow
pretty incredible conversation thanks
for calling in I don't think I've had
that one before I've got a lot of
different calls in 30 years on the show
but I don't think I've had that one I
did meet a kid that was doing that farm
thing or something on the Internet
and he was 18 and his dad was there with
him at an entree leadership event and he
was 18 years old his dad and his brother
his older brother both worked for him
and he had made four million dollars
with these add-ons to that farm thing
the kids play on the Internet where you
built a farm or whatever it is I coming
and you buy you buy stuff to get more
sheep or whatever it is on how it works
but he had made four million bucks at
eighteen years older than that so I mean
I mean I mean them occasionally they're
out there but why
all pretty pretty amazing stuff yeah
just build an app that's all you need to
do then everything's gonna be okay